yes they all are
are they really yeah I've been on all of
them they're all at 2:30 nope this is
normal well this is garyvee this is a
big moment for us we've been waiting for
you thank you
we've got our ideologue show happening
today
yep Gary's gonna be the keynote speaker
can't wait thought we would squeeze in a
little late-night taping of you to get
some of the down and dirty you know who
is Gary thought to do it I did bring
because I know you're a big Jetson I am
and I brought Ryan Fitzpatrick's really
bad yes I see him he's here his name's
Mike and he's our sidekick you know
right Ryan's benched this week so I
guess he has some downtime hurts hurts I
guess my first question yeah head into
the nitty-gritty shorts
why the Jets you know I was born in the
Soviet Union we came here when I was
three know the Jets are not known out
there but I I came in late 70s when we
you know when I first kind of you know
this is late 70s early 80s kids went
outside and played it was a different
generation when I first went out I
didn't I wasn't Americanized I didn't
have that common bond with the kids
outside and one early you know one day
in first grade there was a group of kids
playing football they asked me what my
favorite football team was I said I'm
not even sure if I remember if I spoke
English
all that much and they said well you're
a Jets fan like us and I was like okay
and basically that's Sunday
I watched my first Jets game and I have
not missed a play a play of a New York
Jets game since 1982
I lived in for most of my life
yes now I'm down in Florida yes I'm
having a difficult time because I was a
Giants fan yes here in the city and then
went down to Miami and I'm not doing so
well either what the Dolphins yeah so
we've got a lot of work to do I
understand it's bad times in football
seriously you know what's funny I've
never played this is my first season
Cris Collinsworth who has this kind of
celebrity serious league and so I did it
for branding to be honest
I'm five and one because because like
most things very talented just I but I
don't like to play it because I think
you understand my life is very simple
the health and happiness of my family
the New York Jets my business in that or
in that order and so I'm a simple man
and the Jets are truly and this is not a
joke the Jets are my true escapism I
take it very seriously but I have it
contextualized of what it means in the
scheme of things
it's the one thing in the world that I
care enough about that if something bad
is happening in business it is not in my
mind in those four hours and that's
healthy and I think we all need that
whether that's reading meditation
traveling I know mine's weird but it
doesn't make it any less real and I need
that escapism and it's tough when a
season like this happens when the games
become kind of not as important I'm not
as invested but I I go and I watch and I
support but yeah it's a big deal for me
yeah yes what is the most valuable today
attention attention if we're talking the
context of who I know is watching before
he can tell me how great you are at your
craft or how great your product is or
why I should come and see you
you need my attention and so if you're
talking in a place where the end
consumer is no longer paying attention
to you're in deep [ __ ]
and so when you're spending an ungodly
amount of money on Direct Mail or
outdoor media or television or
traditional digital like banner ads or
pre-rolls I don't think that's as a
valuable to move as something like what
you're doing right now which is a
content
play or Facebook or Instagram or
snapchat and so I've been pulling the
levers of attention since I was a
six-year-old trying to sell lemonade and
try to figure out which pole or tree to
put my sign on that would sell more cups
of lemonade I used to think about how I
would it's funny this is perfect I used
to do baseball card shows and I would
literally sit there and people used to
think I had some sort of either weird
disease or was like super kind of like
you know wired in a weird way because I
would sit and think about the layout of
my cards for two hours before the mall
would open and then would watch how
people would look at my table I've been
following attention my whole life when I
was dragged in my dad's liquor store
when I was 14 and started working there
you know there was some of the guys that
thought I was weird because I wasn't
working but all I was doing was just
literally watching the pattern of how
somebody would walk through the store
later I understood the biggest retailers
in the world had cameras following us
and understood ui/ux and all this stuff
or the shelf at a bar why are those
products there but that came to me as
natural as you can imagine is my natural
gift to understand where consumers
attention is a little bit faster than
the marketplace which is has been the
foundation of my success I mean it's the
whole thing right I mean when I do I
talk a lot about yeah I mean I think and
I just don't I don't know what else to
say I mean I think all of us here in the
city everybody watch again home like
times the game like you can do anything
you want you could have all the money
success connections nobody's figured out
how to add that 25th hour and and yeah I
think time is super important you know
uber my investment in uber was a big one
I passed on uber in the angel round
which would have been ungodly you know
really tough to say that publicly that I
left those three hundred million dollars
on the table not only that pass on it I
passed on it twice not only that it gets
worse
my first business got crush it I thanked
my entire fee
and one random human being the
co-founder and CEO of uber Travis who's
a dear friend of mine for a long time I
didn't understand it the first time when
I invested in a little bit later so I'll
do ok I realize holy [ __ ]
uber doesn't sell transportation uber
sells the perception of time and I
believe that any company in today's
world that takes time and resells it
back to people will build the biggest
companies in the world and so even the
way I think about advertising if you're
trying to if I'm trying to watch this
YouTube video but you put a banner a
pre-roll before it you stole my time I
came here to watch this not to see this
car driving up a hill and so time is the
asset by the way by a small group of
here by show of hands I know everybody
can't see this at home but I'll do color
commentary for you but show of hands how
many people here are now mad when
another human being calls them raise
your hand think think about that half
this room just raise their hands think
about asking that question 10 years ago
it just wouldn't even emit sets we now
know there's other ways to use
technology like you text me and I'll get
back to you on my time that's why it's
rude and so time has become the thing
that we've put on a pedestal because for
some of us in this room we're not 18
year olds we're not 16 year olds we
remember the world when it used to
actually shut off at 6:00 or 7:00 p.m.
professionally and you'd get to it
tomorrow that world does not exist you
get people emailing you at 11:00 p.m.
there's some sort of expectation that
you may get back to them we live in 24/7
365 world where were pounded by
information and so now we subconsciously
we've formed into this enormous belief
and value around time and it's precious
and I do reverse engineer a lot of my
strategies around how to not steal time
yes yes yes
prioritize what you invest you know it's
funny I think of it almost in Reverse
event yes that's all true and you can
list all the other things it makes me
overwhelmingly focused on not wasting
the other person's time because then I'm
bringing the most value the keynote I'm
about to give it's not a canned speech I
think you know that I know who's in the
audience you know and I'm gonna think
about what can I talk about that's gonna
bring them the most value yesterday
morning in Orlando at the AMA where it's
the biggest TV advertisers in the world
I talked about something completely
different so that's predicated on
actually valuing people's time I don't
want them to sit there for 45 minutes
and zone out or not get any value
they're sitting there even this
interview I'm like obsessed at the
highest level of like okay who's
watching his show got it that demo what
can I say that's practical to them that
they can take away and do something with
and I just do that with my employees
with my customers with my audience and I
think that's why I'm successful because
if you bring more value than you ask for
in return you win in life let alone
business yeah
I've always thought you know
hairdressers are interesting and I think
the service industry as a whole is an
interesting information whatever but a
hairdresser has 45 minutes well you know
what's funny it's happy it's funny where
you went with that I think and you guys
know this better than I do but I know
this is a common sense savvy human
individual on earth I think people
really enjoy some their time by the way
you have to reverse everybody one by one
you have to have the EQ skills and the
empathy to understand is this person
really valuing time and wants to get out
of here and if I can do this in 37
minutes instead of 44 minutes I'm gonna
actually make them happy and then
there's other people who are running a
mile a minute and this is a time to kind
of let go and enjoy and escape into your
guy's world with them and maybe that's
really 49 minutes I think the place that
you guys need to focus on as an industry
is not necessarily the execution of your
craft and your art but how one gets to
that moment I don't want to waste my
time to book I don't want to waste my
time to like change
or the infrastructure to get the mayor
or discover you is where you need to
completely save time once they're there
now you're getting into an entire
experience thing I think you could go
the other way I think you're gonna have
somebody I think people are somebody
like me if this is something that
they're passionate about would rather
spend an hour and a half in the
experience but save two out of the four
minutes on the execution to get there
yes that is honor focus just on the
craft yes yes yes okay it kind of popped
up and they're using social media to get
their clients yes using social media to
to get people in the chair yes we're in
the old school days you had to go and
actually hand business cards out on the
street or wait for your customers and
you cut to tell other people to come to
you for a haircut but now you're getting
people that three years in the business
there you know booked twenty a day six
months out and they're charging $800 a
haircut it's actually happening so
what's that course about because it's up
ended the entire industry so you know
things you're talking about are all kind
of playing out technology is a son of a
[ __ ] technology doesn't care that
you've been unbelievable at your craft
for 30 years right technology didn't
care that my dad's contemporaries that
came over from Russia in 1978 moved to
LA made 2 bucks an hour being a cab
driver work 20 hours a day saved every
dollar for 13 years had you know paid
their dues could didn't see their family
saved all their money bought a couple of
black cars actually built a business
saved all their money worked every day
for 30 years finally getting to the
moment where eating all that [ __ ] might
pay off just a little bit and then uber
came along and put them out of business
like technology didn't care that you or
grandfather came from Europe worked 80
hours a day for his whole life
built a small little book store your dad
came along your mom came along made it
bigger now it was your turn
it's a real great piece and you're gonna
take it and Amazon came along and put
you out of business technologists thing
here like like I don't know what to tell
you like this is called capitalism this
is the way it works like I understand
how you want it to be romantically I
understand that you want it to be in
your best vested interest do you know
Matt I am that Twitter is not the number
one social network in the world from
2007 to 2011 I spent 14 hours a day
answering people's questions on Twitter
let me just say this one more time
there's people watching a couple people
know this truth for you you just don't
believe it because it makes no [ __ ]
sense 14 hours a day I spent on Twitter
replying to anything anybody said about
wine and then for the back half of a
year or so business and did it every day
and became one of the 50 most followed
people on Twitter it was my break out to
the world do you know how amazing it
would be for me if Twitter was Facebook
right now and was the number one
platform in the world but it's not and
nobody's crying for me and nobody's
gonna cry for you and nobody's gonna cry
for anybody that's the point
and so of course that's happening this
always happens but I mean I don't
understand what people you know
including the people that got exposure
from you know what's the difference of
somebody hustling on social media to
build their business and somebody doing
a good job 20 years ago and the New York
Times writing a piece about them nothing
they get the only difference is people
now can actually take full control of
the customers intention and not be at
the mercy of a middleman and mainstream
media so yeah of course that's happening
yes yes my high school friends email me
on Facebook and the opening line is
you're so lucky and then i black out and
don't read anything else and i reply to
them and say rick that's awesome but i
need to remind you something remember in
high school and then college when you
went to the jersey shore and drank a
bunch of beers and hooked up with chicks
I [ __ ] worked
so I'd prefer that people keep that luck
[ __ ] in their pocket okay
you know big which means just you know
and by the way I was born in the Soviet
Union because Khrushchev two presidents
before I was even born
came to America and so saw corn being
planted everywhere and he was such an
idiot
he went back to Russia and planted corn
in all of the Soviet Union which it
couldn't actually work there and so big
that started the process of them having
a resource issue which led to 1976 them
making a deal with Israel and the United
States to get rid of Jews which they had
no interest in to begin with out of
Russia in exchange for wheat that is
luck I was lucky to be born and a
serious event that I'm comfortable with
there's a lot of things that love
there's a lot of I believe in luck I
just think it's a tough thing to start
with when you talk to somebody who
basically since he was 14 years old has
been working 15 hours a day every day
always and forever and as you know
because I have a good sense that you
know this the reason d-roc and I started
dailyvee my vlog which is now 80
episodes in is I talk about hard work
I just realized after four or five years
that people didn't believe me so now I
just documented really hard to debate
when I've got the hard footage of 7:00
a.m. to midnight every day every day
every day every day
he's with you all that time yeah poor
guy yeah I mean the poor guy can't you
know by the way the other thing is I
don't believe in that many different
things right so I don't even know how he
gets through a day of hearing this the
same [ __ ] but yeah I mean I think I
think I believe in hard work here's what
I can tell you you everybody watching at
home you do not know a single person on
earth that became successful because of
themselves without hard work they just
don't exist they don't exist you know
some people that inherited grandma's
money and the rich but nobody made
themselves successful without hard work
it just doesn't it's impossible
do little history looking because that's
I didn't even I didn't know the Jews
were traded for wheat
yes we sure were I was trading things to
get trained by the way with the amount
of taxes that I've paid in my life that
was a great trade yeah I get it
the 70s you know Gary another concept
you talk about I kind of want to get
some of these go ahead let's do it I'll
go fast rate for it no these are great
for hairdresser sure no rush okay you
talk about everyone always talks about
failing and you talk about you know
being scared of failing too and I love
that I think I think cuz that really
gets the essence of it yeah that that's
been hairdressers have a lot of fear
that that's gonna get got it that was a
big one that I didn't realize what I'm
glad you picked up on that people are
scared of failing I think we all know
that I think everybody understands that
it's why so many people don't try I'm I
just somehow stumbled on how lucky I was
that my mom is the greatest human being
on earth and created a self-esteem for
me that is probably somewhat
inappropriate but [ __ ] I would not give
it up for anything because it's made me
very comfortable I think that somehow
someway between DNA and the way I was
parented and my circumstance of
immigration things of that nature I'm in
a funny place where I'm just not scared
I'm just not worried about you know it's
like this weird I could care less what
anybody thinks and I genuinely care what
everybody thinks you know it's the kind
of this really yin and yang and so I
just realized that so many of you are
scared to fail because your dad's gonna
make you feel bad about it and I'm I've
empathy for that that sucks like or or
your or your husband is gonna say I told
you so I'm very fascinated by negative
energy within our ecosystem that is not
cut out of all you can get rid of your
acquaintances that's a [ __ ] right
but when your mom's the dick face you're
in trouble yeah and and so I've been
trying to have this conversation of who
are you scared to fail in front of and I
gotta tell you in one on one's or
meetups where the content has come from
that's the beauty of doing a vlog
content happens in these moments that I
would have never thought of its
it resonates I react to the reaction of
the audience and I and I start trying to
force myself to understand it better
wooof people people are scared like you
know you look up to your older sister
who's straight line and got the lake and
her opinion matters to you but you're an
artist and you want to do this and if
you fail you don't want to fail in front
of her that's tough that's stopping a
lot of us I don't have the answer to
what you have to do about it other than
I do believe that communication solves
all things but great how do I push you
to have that real talk with your mom
hard so yeah man it's it's a real one
but it's not so easy to unwind all my
stuff is very strategic highbrow like
I'm a jersey in the dirt kind of
character so by being the messenger of
this very tried and true very
historically correct very heady
strategic stuff people are confused
because I don't look the part I look the
part of the sizzle not the steak but
that's the beauty of running the
marathon eventually even in this
interview like they'll be like huh you
know like like eventually and I don't
care if that takes just one interview or
the rest of my life I'm very comfortable
that what I'm selling is not flash in
the pan so youth understand I spent 15
years building a business before I was a
personality I didn't I wasn't a 22 year
old life coach on Instagram I put my
head down and built a 65 million dollar
business you know in the dirt in the
trenches working 15 hours a day in a
liquor store and then building an early
e-commerce business before I thought I
had the audacity or even the respect or
platform to even think that I was worth
listening to for 40 minutes right so I
think I earned it and so I understand my
personality traits that may make it seem
like it's fast is it real I'm empathetic
to that but
kind of rolls into that please you talk
about the night I just think it's such
good it's all these are like good things
for young hairdressers to hear okay the
concept of you know making Monday my
[ __ ] okay yes
you know I love that okay because it it
so many times I just know in our
business when we were kind of growing
through the ranks and hiring lots of
people especially you you know people
were to the first job they start to not
like Mondays and would drive me crazy as
it drives you crazy
can you talk to that yeah I mean I think
there's nothing sadder in life than if
you live for the weekends I just like
it's just a math game if you're spending
eighty-three percent of your time 72
percent of your times sixty-four percent
of your time on something you hate
that's devastating I went through it I
hated school at a level that you
couldn't imagine I was a rare version of
an immigrant that education wasn't the
way out and I knew who I was I had
self-awareness coming out of my pores in
fourth grade I knew it already and so
[ __ ] eight more years and when you're
and you know when you're eleven that's
like after you know like you know like
it was devastating like I would like
Sunday nights were devastating a
potential snowstorm was the greatest
moment of my life
you know so I lived it I lived it as a
kid not as serious as being a grown-up
that hates their job no question but at
the time it felt serious right and so I
don't know we live in an age now where
we have your grandparents couldn't do
the things you can do your career pants
didn't didn't have the internet your
grandparents couldn't be practical nine
to five then come home you know do their
family thing and then from 7:00 p.m. to
2:00 in the morning do something online
that could have been the thing that
switched them out of their nine-to-five
and created their freedom they didn't
have that option we do
everybody in this room does we live in a
24/7 world now my big thing that leads
us into is complaining the thing that
rips my heart out of my soul is
complaining if you were genuinely
unhappy if they're genuinely unhappy do
something about it the amount of people
that email me that and complain and then
I go look at their social media and all
they tweet about is Game of Thrones and
FIFA soccer and like I'm like we do with
you
time you are not allowed to complain if
you're on to softball teams you're just
not allowed so I think that um yeah you
know look the one the great positive to
being underestimated for charisma and
showmanship is that you also have
motivational DNA that actually allows
somebody who's listening to be like yes
and that has been the great gift of my
life I struggle with my motivational
tendencies I don't want to be Tony
Robbins or Oprah or a motivational
character I'm much more in tune with
building actual businesses I don't like
the secret you know like I don't like
that stuff
however however it's very difficult to
me when I get a you know when I get 10
to 15 emails a day from people like you
changed my life I watch this video for
some reason I've heard it before but the
way you said it made me do this and my
life is better whether it was that or
start a business and it's funny I've
been going through a very difficult time
and I mean it was a high-class problem
but for me I've been really struggling
with I've come to realize that I'm
really holding back on my motivation for
the last five years has been a selfish
act you know cuz I want to be known as a
businessman not as a guru but I've
helped so many more people in the last
six months that I've opened up a little
bit more of that so it's an interesting
journey right now for me on that on that
switching gears yeah yeah go ahead go
ahead Bri be good talk to me not
allowing me to talk would know even
better I was gonna take you to an island
yes and literally drop us off with no
Wi-Fi yes connectivity sounds romantic
yeah what yeah it is a little strange
how how would you how would you I would
I would I really shut you down I think
I'm a chameleon here's what would happen
you totally adapt correct I would be a
disaster in the beginning maybe dead
right
like dead like the first two three four
five days I'd be like eating sand and
like like trying to kill you with like a
shell like that's right but but by day
12 14 20 I would recon text I've been
really you know no I'd probably need you
more in the beginning right you know
because I need that interaction but over
time I think yeah I mean I'm comfortable
you know ironically ironically my two
favorite places are the airplane in the
bathroom did you do cuz I'm by myself
like I'm super you know I love myself I
could be with myself and so I know no
but but if I but if I need to it's very
easy for me to do that yeah you
understand and this is just like you're
getting pretty heady here if your only
thing in life is the health of your
family you're pretty happy a lot yeah
unfortunately you can get really sad you
know like if I get a text right now that
my sister's in a car accident things are
really bad I'm shut out in a way that
you could like I don't know if I ever
come back I don't come back until that's
resolved so you know it's really easy
for me to shut off or shut on or not
like when you were as binary as the
health and well-being of my family comma
nothing else then all the way over here
the Jets and then business like a you
know it's it's really easy to be happy
and I and I do challenge everybody to
start really building perspective you
know we really struggle with it we've
lived during the greatest we lived
during the greatest era of the greatest
empire of human race if an American if a
white American male does not realize
that they have won the ultimate lottery
a
the universe in America during its
greatest era as an empire then I've got
nothing for them like like genuinely
generally if I became the dictator of
America I would make it a life sentence
in jail for a white American male to
complain at all
you mean the the are live your mother
statement or do you mean like I've got I
go with it look I mean ROI is like
what's the return on your investment I
go through it from a lot of ways
historically and this is a more
old-school I used to always talk about
what's the ROI of your mother everybody
wants to measure everything how do I
like I can tell you that I will
literally buy a multi-billion dollar
sports organization one day in my life
in 30 years and the complete ROI is the
way my parents parented me I can't
quantify it I can't show you a chart
that on May 16th when I got this shitty
haircut my mom still said I was the best
looking boy on earth like I can't give
you that data point but I know it
happened and I know what it did for me
right so you know I can't show you in a
chart that Oh on April 13th 1986 I
opened the door for a woman at
McDonald's is a true story not the date
but I opened the door for an elderly
woman at McDonald's instead of just
running in and my mom spent the next 17
days acting as if I won the Nobel Peace
Prize right you know I can't I can't
show you that but I think about ROI in a
lot of places look return on investment
first of all I believe that in the
digital world people are confused they
may say Google's working but what they
don't realize was it was a video on
Facebook that made somebody search for
you on Google and then click that ad was
that Google no it wasn't Google's a
tollbooth of society and it gets credit
for driving your business way more than
actually does it right ROI I think
people do a lot of things for the value
of it today instead of 23 years from now
I'm not doing this interview right
for the value of your viewership today
I'm doing it for the fact that it's an
ecosystem that I'm not as involved with
and maybe 13 years from now something of
somebody learning about me today brings
me value and even better I'm not even
worried about cashing in on that chip
bottom line is we live in a world where
99% of people are running a sprint and
the reality is that life's the marathon
and that's that and so when I think
about ROI I think of it in short and
long term I need some things to get by
right on a day to day basis I need money
from clients to pay for my employees
like I gotta pay rent I got to run a P&L
but the amount of people that draw lines
and send spec work I'm not gonna cut
this person's hair for free even though
they're famous or important isn't that
it's the stupidest thing of all time
that word of mouth could be exponential
to the growth of your business but
people do people draw religious lines in
the sand on ideological notions that
destroy the upside of their long term
are we talking mascara me yeah my fourth
my fourth New York Times best-selling
book by the way that was for all my
English teachers that gave me D's and
F's because they are spinning right now
like how the [ __ ] did that happen I mean
it's the state of the union of marketing
and entrepreneurship and operations and
the my State of the Union I did do a
YouTube show called askgaryvee I take
questions from social media and I just
answer them and you know there's
chapters on parenting while being
somebody who's super ambitious and
there's tact and there's questions on
tactics on Pinterest to drive a
transaction it's so it's an
all-encompassing state of the union of
the things that have made me successful
and the things that have made people
want to follow me but the most
encompassing the other three books were
very very business driven there was a
lot more EQ leadership you know dealing
stress it was a very more rounded very
more rap and look I mean we all know
this right is as hot shot as I thought I
was at 25 I'm a much stronger better
version of myself at 40 experience
actually matters it's real and and I
feel like I'm I'm becoming more in tune
and tapping into some of the subtleties
that have made me successful
other than the black and white tactics I
want by the way when I say successful
I'm gonna recall it because it's
important I make money I could make a
lot more money if I was willing to be
less successful when I'm means
successful I mean the balance of being
more proud about how you make your money
than how much you make on the balance of
being more worried about your legacy
than your currency on the balance of
like thinking about what your grandkids
are gonna think of you and most of all
the number one way I run my life how
many people can I guilt into coming to
my funeral that is the number one way
that I live my life if you ask me what
my global North Star is my entire game
is predicated on how many people show up
to my funeral because showing up to
funerals actually and it's interesting I
I no longer like the Yankees and the
Rangers I'm going in a little bit of an
interesting direction like because both
of those teams want championships for me
so now I obsess over the Knicks and the
Jets
I love the climb I love the journey and
it was interesting when I thought about
this as his funeral thing started
happening over the last 10 years I was
like wait a minute
that's the ultimate journey my whole
life is this journey the payoff is the
funeral and I don't even get to know how
it plays out I'm not even there so so I
think it's fascinating I've been
fascinated by the funerals that I've
gone to and the ones that I haven't as I
become more busy and travel and it's
really predicated on heart / brain or
wallet or other things right and so yeah
man I think so
Millennials are you know it's just a
generation and they understand
efficiency naturally
yes something that kind of just comes to
them yes and how older generations can
easily adapt and thrive by doing so
because you're not on Leno yeah I think
this millennial I think this mom I even
when you brought it up earlier
I think this millennial talk is wack
like let me tell you why I've 600 or so
500 of our 800 employees at vaynermedia
are under 28 and 25% of them only care
about working all day and night and
making as much money as possible and
then I know 48 year olds that want
work/life balance and they're like like
stereotypes are have truths I'd respect
that but all of this is always a mindset
I'm I you know like this is a mindset
this isn't how old you are this is how
you are wired and I think that
Millennials have gotten a bad rap for
their work ethic and for their audacity
and there's plenty of them but there was
plenty of those people 20 years ago too
we just didn't categorize them I've run
businesses for a long time 20 years ago
long before those Millennials there was
plenty of 25 year olds that came into my
business that thought they should be
running the company that's a DNA trait
you know that is not an age thing and so
on the older generation let's call it 35
and above there's a lot of excuses going
around well I think grow up with this
stuff no [ __ ] you didn't grow up driving
either and you learned like like you we
learn things I think what happens is a
lot of people are lazy and get tired and
are burnt out and they don't want to put
in the work
blows my mind that everybody watching
here isn't willing to watch or read for
20 hours about Facebook Instagram
snapchat you know you know these
platforms that are the relevancy of our
society like you can literally watch 20
hours of YouTube videos on how do I run
Facebook ads how to make create a fort
like you just type it in and you now
know especially if you actually do it
while you not just read it and so
literally I don't know in a week anybody
in the world that has capacity to learn
it's more about understating how you
learn you need to listen you need to
watch do you need to read can actually
be very strong at all this stuff
the punchline is people like excuses
people don't want to put in the work
that's fine more for me yes yeah I think
fast follower is a good model like you
see something that's successful just
moving quickly and trying to learn from
those behaviors is very very interesting
lift lifts a very big business they
didn't invent lifts they saw uber nor
like I don't know we don't think uber is
gonna get everything Google who will saw
yeah who you know you know Facebook
do you remember myspace like fast
following is good yes yes please I'm not
sure do I collect anything yes I used to
collect a lot of things but I always
bought things just to sell them as a
matter of fact I'm in a really bad mood
because it looks like it's gonna rain
tomorrow and I can't take my my kids
garage saling and like Bice
like get buy something for 25 cents at a
garage sale and selling it for $4 and
me a bigger high than landing a five
million dollar account the thrill of the
hunt you actually you actually do that I
did it last weekend there's a lot of
people I I get a lot of emails from
people who are like I'm on welfare I'm
homeless I get emails I'm homeless you
know I'm a single mom with four kids a
lot of people not my silicon fancy
friends are not emailing me these are a
lot of people that are watching my
content some way somehow who $100 a week
is life-changing I you know I know this
make sounds very weird but going to
garage sales spending three dollars and
making $100 on eBay is stunningly
practical if you have a smartphone which
unbelievably people that are homeless
and Welfare do you know everybody has
one no matter what your financial
situation is it seems that almost
everybody has gotten to a place where
they have a smartphone which is
incredible and is maybe the most
optimistic thing I know on life this can
happen and so last weekend I just did
what I always do which is I showed
people by the way it was a great week by
the way one crazy thing stuffed animals
yes stuffed animals here's why they're
at every garage sale and consistently
they're 50 cents or $1 and consistently
they're ten to twenty dollars on eBay if
you know what to look for
Disney Store exclusive that's a good one
but you know like so yeah I mean and by
the way by the way Andy Brooke you know
this like you understand here's the
payoff for me it's Friday this happened
Saturday 25 emails already like like
you're not constantly I'm hot on it
right now I did it I did it I did it but
but you know what you know what I
collect I collect people for sure at
some level I love people
boy do I really like people and like in
all our flaws and I like I really
understand it
yeah I've great retention but even if
they don't like like I just genuinely
like people I understand people it's
what I understand innately the best and
I have a lot of empathy a lot and I
really want to talk about real [ __ ]
right I want to talk about not you know
how everybody's like don't be scared go
do it no no it was about who are you
scared - yeah then you get people like I
want to go that one step that I think a
lot of people you know what's funny the
world is very interesting people that
were born with the gift that I was born
with which is understanding people are
unfortunately not born with the same
other trait that I have which is they
use that to their leverage to their
financial benefit the thing that I'm
most proud of and why I believe a lot of
people will show up to my funeral is
when you have what I have you usually
sell it I'm giving it away for free and
that's a big deal and that's why most
people don't talk about that next step
because that's the thing they get paid
thirty five thousand dollars a month for
when they coach you or life coach you or
when you go to their Island
or this that and the other thing got it
final question he had ever given to the
social media saying that we can not use
it yep and the young generation does it
already okay you still see a lot of
frustration when people can't build
their followers and you talk about this
quite a bit where it's like well you
might not be interesting right we're
gonna end on a we're gonna end on a high
it's called self awareness let's end on
the greatest high self awareness you
might not be interesting and or you may
not know how to communicate that
interesting
in today's world yet nobody's entitled
to followers you don't open an Instagram
account and then like you win that's
like buying a basketball and thinking
you're going to the NBA yeah we are but
we're out of time but we are gonna have
you back yeah so I think you're going
back to your office and then coming back
that is true right not too far so we'll
see you soon for new muscles so thanks
for having me thank you thank you guys